what's going on everybody welcome to
part 9 of the Django web development
with Python tutorial in this tutorial
what we're going to be talking about is
foreign keys basically with with Django
and so what what is the purpose of
foreign keys the idea is that we can
have different tables in our database
that are related to each other now why
might we want to do this well in the
case this is one case example but this
is definitely not an uncommon thing with
all kinds of things such as with
attributes for users and so on so
consider a scenario with like Python
programming dotnet where I've got 1,200
tutorials I can't throw all 1,200
tutorials on the home page we've got to
organize in some way so then we're like
okay well we can wear it as by series
okay but I still have a hundred series
okay
we organized by a category like data
analysis and games in web development
and so on okay so when we organized by
category we could just add another you
know attribute to our tutorial which
would in theory add another column to
the table and their input the the
category itself but I'm not sure that's
exactly the way we want to do it more
likely it's the case that we would want
to make a separate model entirely a
separate database table entirely and and
do things there rather than you know
expanding our database to be you know
just have this one single singular table
for all tutorials in like 15 columns
when we come up with a bunch of extra
attributes so anyways we're going to use
foreign keys to relate our database
tables so with that let's get into it so
the first thing we need to do is go into
our models apparently I don't have
models open I'm just going to close
pretty much everything here so
models we don't need you ballsed up high
here okay mmm and for now what I'm gonna
do is we're just gonna create a new
model and we're gonna say class and this
will be tutorial category and just like
the other one
it's moddable and Harriet for models dot
model now we're gonna do tutorial
category equals models dots car fields
and here we're gonna say max whoops max
length equals 200 now up into this point
a couple things a one person asked hey
why do you do like this tutorial
underscore why not just category why not
just title content published because I'm
not doing that I as I'm writing it out
and as I was going over that I was like
oh that's kind of dumb I agree with you
a really it should just be like you
should have like tutorial dot because
like if you were to say tutorial dot
title that feels better okay so go back
go ahead make that change it's a better
change I approve of your change I
encourage you guys to change it and just
change it run a migrate and you're good
to go yeah so anyways I'm gonna continue
with that naming convention but I I do
think that probably get rid of the
underscore so anyway is continuing along
category the next oh the other thing I
want to say is so if this was the only
thing we were gonna do with category
right yeah we probably would just put
another column here you know that would
make more sense so when you only have
one attribute right and and that
attribute doesn't have any other related
attributes it probably does make more
sense just add it to this table here's
the problem well when we have a category
like when we go to the real Python
programming gannett we see there's a few
things here there's an image there's
obviously the title but then there's
like a disk
and then there's a URL like when we
click on that it takes us to a specific
link right that's attributes that are
associated with that category so in
reality we're not adding one column
we're gonna add like three columns okay
so so we need to to keep that in into
consideration and really it would have
been four it's just we're not gonna deal
with the imagery for now imagery will
have to be way down the line because
there's what is it I think it's called
media there's like static and media and
Django for what for some reason likes to
separate those two out so I want to make
sure I get that one right
well because normally what I would do I
would just throw everything in static
and that seems to be the way to go but
it almost looks like Django is more
prepared for everyone to be using maybe
their own custom image server or like a
CDN or something so anyway I want to
make sure I get that right before I
throw that in a tutorial so we'll skip
the imagery aspect anyway so we'll only
have three attributes but still mmm
because you got the category right then
you've got category summary and in this
case it's models dot karf field and
actually yeah that is camelcase car
field or I suppose you'd call that title
cased car field hit again we'll go with
a max length of 200 I think it's a good
length and then we will add category
slug that's for the URL and again
models.com field and we will stick with
a max length equals 200 now that's all I
wanted to do in my notes I actually have
it written out as default equals one
here if you ever change a model chances
are you're gonna have to throw in a
default it's just gonna require it of
you like it won't default to none or
null I want to say you can pass
something to be null but at least right
now I don't think I need to pass a
default because we're not adding the
column everything's like fresh
so as you add a category that's going to
be there for us to input so I don't
think I need that even though it's in my
notes usually that bites me in the butt
something hits me but I can't think of a
reason why I would need that so not
gonna worry about it okay class Mehta
aver bows name plural so this is just
for us when we see it categories in our
admin page so so that we don't have
category II as in like tutorial category
YS we're just gonna say categories
because Django wants to do that for
whatever reason and then finally we'll
give the dunder string method here and
we'll override that to be returned self
dot tutorial category okay so that's the
category now we could take tutorial and
give tutorial a foreign key that points
to category but a tutorial doesn't
actually point to a category it points
to a tutorial series first so actually
what we could do is take the tutorial
point that to a series and in that
entire series points to a category
because the series is all under the same
category so no need to do to point both
a tutorial and a cat I'm sorry both a
tutorial and the tutorial series to a
category okay so now we're gonna add
another class we're gonna call this
class tutorial series again it inherits
from models dot model and tutorial
series is a models dot car field and
again max length will go lengths will go
to sir 200 okay and then sausage
tutorial series now we're gonna say
tutorial category equals models dot full
foreign key now this is a foreign key to
what tutorial category again I have a
default written here I'm
so in this case tutorial is gonna point
to tutorial series and we're not gonna
actually have something assigned yet and
I bet it will get angry with us so I am
gonna set a default to 1
just because we're adding this after the
fact so because we're doing this oh you
know what this actually probably
probably won't need the default here
when we're gonna need the default is
when we add the foreign key to tutorial
because tutorials already exist and
we're gonna add this new column but for
all the tutorials that already exist
they won't have a value for that column
and the migrate it's gonna be angry with
us so you could add a default here I'm I
don't think a defaults gonna be required
there so much so I'm just not gonna put
one and let's see if we get away with it
we're both named whoops call this
category and then I'm gonna chain let's
see we'll say here on delete this is let
me just write this out and I'll explain
this set default so oh okay this one we
will give a default equals one okay so
lots to explain here mostly these I
guess this really so on delete in the
past on delete would default to cascade
and all that meant was if you deleted
let's say you delete a let's say a
tutorial category was deleted well what
would you want to do with all the
associated objects or vice-versa for
example right in this case i want to use
the defaults rather than rather than
getting rid of like so if we delete a
tutorial category that category no
longer exists should we delete that all
the tutorial series that are in that
category I don't think so so so we're
just gonna set to default which will
just be one right so that makes the most
sense
so that's what we're gonna do naturally
we would want to do that can you imagine
how many people got got gotten by the
default cascade this way it forces you
to look up what happens and think about
what what do I want to happen when I
delete these things I'd be pretty angry
okay so tutorial category all right so
now what we're gonna do is series same
thing before basically series summary
equals models dot car field almost
sounds like Garfield and then max length
200 okay hmm I think I'm actually we
basically have to make it's like it's
such a similar thing every time this
will be series and then down here self
dot tutorial series okay so very similar
structure to the above and then finally
we need to point tutorial to tutorial
series so all we're gonna do we've got
title content published we're gonna
point here let me just come down here
zoom in a little bit okay we're gonna
say tutorial underscore series not camel
case series equals models models dot
foreign key and that foreign key here is
the tutorial series that it's a part of
the default will be one will specify the
verbose name as well as the on delete so
verbose name equals series seer series
and then on delete we want two models
dot set underscore default I just want
see that with my eyeballs thank you sir
all looks good to me
now a tutorial series I'm going to do
the same thing I do on Python
programming Dannette we don't really
need a unique URL for the tutorial
series in my opinion the series is one
of two things either when someone clicks
on that tutorial series it poops them in
to tutorial number one right or if you
wanted to get really fancy the last
tutorial or the latest tutorial part
that that user left off on but that
would be dynamic by user so otherwise
it's just the first tutorial in the
series so that should be good enough so
so we don't need a URL for that but we
do need a URL for the tutorial itself so
I'm going to add that in and we're gonna
say tutorial underscore slug equals
models dot you guessed it it's another
car field and we'll say max length
equals 200 and here we definitely want
to add a default because tutorials
already exist when they have a few of
them but they do exist so we need to
have some sort of default to throw in
the ones that exist already okay so what
have we done well we've made changes to
the model so we need to make migrations
and we need to migrate so let is this
what did I fullscreen this hmm what have
I done
there you go ethyl good ol f11 saves the
day minimize that okay let me just close
that come over here come into my site
see MD Python managed PI make migrations
we've made so many changes and in fact
someone comment down below if I have
failed a migration before and I can't
seem to find out what do you do when the
migration doesn't work because you you
like what files do I need to modify to
get it to skip a specific migration
number
if anybody knows comment below I don't
know what the heck you're watching for
but the few times I've hit errors I've
like tried I've even purposely spawned
errors just to see like what do you do
when you hit an error and honestly I
don't know because you can't get rid of
the migration ah there's got to be
somewhere you could roll back in like
there's probably like a migration number
that you're on so delete the migration
roll back that number you're probably
fine
but I want to say I've tried that and it
didn't work so anyway if you can
especially right now it's super easy
back up before you run really you can
make the migration but mostly back up
before you actually do the migrate so
you can see here everything's looking
fine so far Python managed calm my grade
it looks good I'm really surprised I
almost always write errors so oh alright
so now we're coming down the homestretch
fellas and felt let's oh oh admin oh
it's like how do we lose that okay so
alright so so the things that we've
added have really the homepage hasn't
changed now we should be able to go in
mmm even tutorial that stuff hasn't been
registered so we actually shouldn't see
any change and we do not bump bump um
okay so what we have to do is come over
and Bop into admin dot pi and we need to
import not only tutorial hmm what also
tutorial series and tutorial category so
tutorial tutorial series and tutorial
category okay so then we could come down
here and and we we will I suppose we can
register let's just do it right up above
here so admin dot sight dot R edges can
we type please register and we'll
register tutorial series and then we'll
do admin dot sight red
stur tutorial category save that come
over here just go back to the home page
boom okay so we've got categories and
series so we click on category there
exists no category we could click on
this we could say fundamentals
fundamentals learn Python and stuff
categories okay right right Python I
don't know
OOP no let's not do slash either let's
just say Python - fundamentals the - I
don't know I'm not even getting into it
but we're not gonna have the - there or
slash anyway save boom done we have a
category and we could do the same thing
with series but I don't want to do that
just yet in fact because probably more
likely what you'd want to do is you come
into tutorials you'd want to add a
tutorial and then you would just simply
want to say this tutorial is a part of
such-and-such series and then in this
series you'd actually like to say as you
create a new series you're gonna say hey
this series is part of such a such
category or something like that is more
likely the way that you were going to go
about doing something but what we're
gonna do now you got title dates we also
need so much effort let's do this let's
copy this we want a URL and then we want
the series so URL series so here we'll
say URL and then here we'll say series
and this will be a tutorial slug and
then this will be tutorial series series
cool
I think that we're all set there so
we'll save that let's come back over
here bloop let's click on just one of
these tutorials slug is kind of silly ok
so then here we have a new you are a new
section for series obviously we don't
have any series so let's just add a
series now by using this lovely little
plush isn't this awesome so then you can
add a series right here so what is a
series Python basics part of
fundamentals the category will be
fundamentals learn to do things with
Python ok save done boom save done
awesome so now you might even add a
series this way right same thing as we
just did basically just no pop-up right
so now everything is kind of related but
we don't need to have just like one
giant table alright and instead a
tutorial is related to your category by
way of its relationship through series
right instead of having like five extra
columns in one massive table because
categories in series is going to be you
know small very small table series might
be 100 tall and then categories is gonna
be like I don't know 6 or 7 right so it
saves you a ton of space and it just
makes more sense to organize things that
way so anyway it's just a super basic
example of how we would do all that now
before we get to the next tutorial I
want to talk about okay now that we've
created the model to organize things how
do we then organize our actual homepage
to look that way right because right now
it's just showing us all of the
tutorials so how would we get the home
page to look more like this home page
where you've got the the main categories
here and then when you click on
something you see maybe some tutorial
series and then when you click on that
you get the actual tutorials themselves
how do we get ourselves to that point so
that's what we're gonna do in the next
tutorial and before you get there I'm
not gonna I don't want to waste anyone's
time
what you need to do is add you know make
make sure there's I don't know two or
three categories add you know two or
three or add anywhere between one and
three tutorial series per category and
add like two or three tutorials per
series and if you want you can just like
you like there you can just like Google
like what is that lorem ipsum stuff if
some this stuff and copy and paste that
in give it some sort of title just make
up the data but just do that it'll
probably take like I don't know five
minutes nice don't want to waste time
doing that for five minutes on video
just make sure you've got some way of
organizing some things so later in the
next tutorials when we start doing the
visual aspect of this organization you
can still follow along so anyways that's
all for now thanks for watching thanks
for all your support and subscriptions
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below otherwise
I will see you guys in another video